foreign
strangely normal to tell our kids that
they're going to die from climate change
if sea level rises and get them then a
wild firewall or a global famine or crop
failures maybe a fatal Heat Wave the
insect apocalypse or the fishless oceans
these are the headlines we've all been
told will be the end of humanity
so we shouldn't be surprised then that
young people today feel crippled with
anxiety
a large International survey as 10
Frozen young people about their
attitudes to climate change
within half South African humanity is
doomed three quarters find a future
frightening and more than one in three
are hesitant to have children of Their
Own
young people today truly feel that it
could be the last generation
in fact prominent activist groups
actually take on this very name
now I get this feeling I've been there
I used to feel like humanitive is doomed
despite having multiple environmental
degrees felt completely helpless to do
anything about it
but I'm a data scientist and after years
pouring over the data on how far
Humanities come and how quickly things
are now moving my perspective on this
has changed I think we've got this
framing upside down
far from being the last generation I
think you'll be the first generation the
first generation to be sustainable
when we think about sustainability we
might imagine humans have only become
unsustainable in the very recent past
that our ancestors lived in perfect
balance with nature and only recently
has that been knocked off
unfortunately this is not true
if a nostalgic for a sustainable past to
re-round back to there is none
the world has never been sustainable
now forget that that's a controversial
statement so let me explain why we think
about the definition of sustainability
we might imagine something like this
it's having a low environmental impact
to protect future generations and it's
true by this definition many of our
ancestors were sustainable they did have
a low environmental impact
but the reason they had a low
environmental impact is because the
populations were tiny
and the reason their populations were
tiny is because half of children died
before reaching puberty
half of children died
that then reads the question is that
what we really think sustainability is
is that the world we want to maintain
and preserve one where half of our
children die
hope your answer to that is no if we
care about human suffering we need to
add another dimension to this we need to
also write a good life for everyone
today
now that gives our definition two halves
if we fail on either half we have failed
to be sustainable that's where ancestors
were never sustainable they never
achieved the first half of the equation
now over the last few centuries the
world has made amazing progress on the
first half as we show in our own data
chain mortality is now down to four
percent extreme poverty used to be the
default no less than one in ten people
live there
let us say an education used to be real
now most children in the world get the
opportunity to go to school
if the world as it is today is still
unacceptable it's unacceptable that
millions of children die every year it's
unacceptable that hundreds of millions
live on less than two dollars a day
which is incredibly low poverty line
but pick almost any metric of human
well-being and you'll find that the
world has become a much better place
but this progress has come at a cost
it's come across the environment
fuels for energy we expanded farmlands
at the cost of forests and our
insatiable appetite for me means now use
half of the Rose habit of land for
farming we call billions of animals
every year
these are the trends that make us feel
dimmed we see these lines rising and we
assume that they might never stop
but more recently I tell does a slightly
different story a more hopeful story
that we can turn things around
this is per capita CO2 missions in the
UK since 1750.
over the last few decades a missions in
the UK have halved that means that my
carbon footprint today is less than half
that of my grandparents when they were
my age
that's despite the fact I live in much
more struggling lifestyle or as they'd
put at your youngsters just don't know
how good you've got it these days
now you might think the UK is cheating
here it used to be this industrial
Powerhouse now it just gets China and
they are Bangladesh to produce that
stuff for it maybe it's just offshored
all these emissions if there's a bit of
truth to this when we adjust for trade
emissions in the UK are higher
but we still see this dramatic decline
over the last few decades offshoring is
a bit of the story but it's not the
entire story
at the same time the UK has increased
its GDP GDP has gone up while emissions
have come down and it's not the only
country to achieve this you will see the
same for the US for Germany France Spain
Portugal a long list of countries have
increased GDP by reducing their
emissions and again this is not just
because they've offshored them
the notion economic growth has to be
incompatible with reducing our
environmental impact is simply wrong
now rich countries are reducing their
emissions but low and middle income
countries are increasing theirs what
does this mean at a global level well
portal CO2 missions are now beginning to
Flatline but actually emissions per
person already peaked a decade ago that
means the emissions of the average
person in the world today have peaked
and are now falling and we will see a
peak in total CO2 emissions soon
now why is this happening a big driver
has been technological change here we
see co-production in the UK since 1700.
now the UK was the birthplace of
industrial coal and it has now died
there
when I was born more than half of the
UK's electricity was coming from coal
this is no less than two percent
and it's dying in many other countries
too you will see the same for U.S
Germany Denmark Spain Portugal Greece
Ireland and many countries in the world
coal is dying
taking its place are Renewables where
costs are plummeting the cost of solar
has fallen by 99.8 since 1970. so on by
90 in the last decade alone
and if you're worried that it looks like
this price trend is leveling off don't
be when we zoom in we see that the price
of Solar continues to fall
if the same is true for wind go back a
decade and solar and wind were among
most expensive Energy Technologies we
had that is why the world does not make
in progress that is why countries were
not deploying them they were far too
expensive but just 10 years on and that
script has flipped in many countries in
the world solar and wind are now the
cheapest
now if we're going to have Renewables
we're going to need energy storage but
there's good news there too the price of
batteries has fallen by 98 since 1990.
if you take the battery you'd find on a
Tesla today go back to 1990 but of
course one million dollars it now costs
just twelve thousand
that's completely transformed the world
of energy storage and completely
transformed the world of transport
Global sales of petrol and diesel cars
have already peaked the peaked in 2017
and they are now falling taking their
place are electric cars were in the
space of just a few years sales are
going through the roof
now from energy and transport to the
food we eat you might imagine that
Global deforestation at its highest
level ever but actually Global
deforestation decades ago and has now
falling but actually it's better than
that because many countries are now
regrowing their old forests such as the
net decline is even more impressive
now why is this happening a big driver
has been increased in crop yields for
all of our agricultural history crop
yields were low and stagnant Farmers had
basically no opportunities to increase
them
over the last century across many
countries and many different crop types
crop yields have skyrocketed here we see
it for the U.S for corn where yields
have grown six-fold from two tons to 12
tons
now what this means is we can grow a lot
more food from a lot less land amount of
land used to produce corn in the U.S has
not increased in over a century but
looked at the change in corn production
my main point here is that in the past
human progress had to come at the cost
of the environment if we wanted energy
we had to burn wood or we had to burn
fossil fuels we wanted to grow more food
we had to expand Farmland often at the
cost of forests
but technology and Innovation means
we're very quickly decoupling these
impacts such as this conflict is no
longer true
let's then think about the world that we
can have
we need to achieve the first half of our
equation
we need to end Global poverty and here
I'm not talking about raising number one
above a two dollar a day poverty line
that's simply not good enough we need to
provide everyone with a good comfortable
life
no child should die from a cause that's
preventable
every child should get the opportunity
to go to school and get an education
at the same time we need to Peak and
reduce our CO2 emissions we need to move
away from fossil fuels and we need to
end deforestation while feeding 8 9 10
billion people at the same time
how do we do that how do we become the
first generation
first our local Technologies need to
become the default there's two ways to
do this the first is to make sure that
they are affordable to make sure that
they are the cheapest option
solar and wind are already cheaper than
coal electric cars will soon be cheaper
than gasoline and alternative routines
need to be cheaper than meat
the other way to do this is to make sure
that these Technologies are better
environmental products have often been
promoted as this happy gimmick but they
need to go mainstream and for that they
need to be better than the high carbon
alternatives
now my brother recently got an electric
car he didn't get an electric car
because he really really cares about the
environment it does not want to be the
next greater Timber and he definitely
does not want to be like me
he got an electric car because the
design and the Driving Experience were
far better than the petrol alternatives
that is how you make low carbon
Technologies the default
we need to reframe the way we talk about
sustainability it's often promoted as a
sacrifice environmental messaging is
often built on scarcity it's about
reducing our lives back to the bare
minimum and no more
but this is not a vision that inspires
anyone this is not the future we want to
build we need to reframe sustainability
as an opportunity because it is an
opportunity
it's an opportunity to provide clean
abundant energy for everyone whether
it's pairing cities or countries okay in
rural communities connected for the very
first time
it's about not being at the whims of
fossil fuel markets or having millions
Point into fuel poverty when dictators
invade neighboring countries
it's about breathing clean air here we
see the decline and harmful air
pollution in the U.S from 2005 to 2021.
stopping people from dying is not a
sacrifice
finally as a way to rethink the way we
live our lives the way we design our
cities and our communities
here we see Copenhagen where bikes for
the road or Amsterdam we have layer upon
layer of bike track
now I'm not saying this is how our
cities have to look we can design them
in any way we want
what I'm saying is that sustainability
goes the shoved to rethink the way we do
things
finally we need to rethink the way we
use data as a data scientist I take this
very seriously if environmentalists have
done an amazing job of waking the world
up to these problems those charts of
rising CO2 and Rising temperature have
been absolutely critical they're why I'm
on the stage today that why I got
involved in this in the first place
but there's a limit when that's all we
see we become paralyzed we see these
lines rising and we assume that they
might never stop we assume that no
progress has been made that nothing good
is happening
but as we've just seen it this couldn't
be further from the truth
we need to use data to inspire to show
what the problems are also what the
solutions are and we need to show real
signs of progress from countries
individuals companies
historically our sustainability equation
went like this it was one or the other
you could not have both at the same time
we can be the first generation that does
achieve both now the emphasis here is on
can none of this is inevitable in fact
it's not even inevitable that you have
this opportunity in the first place
we're only here because of the
Relentless work of environmentalists
activists scientists engineers
entrepreneurs communicators determined
to make the world a better place
they have brought us here I mean to take
that forward
we need to do it bigger and we need to
do it much much faster
what we do have the opportunity to be
the first generation that builds a
sustainable world let's take it thank
you
[Applause]